GAS WELL AMERICA SUFFERS.
AFTER PENNSYLVANIA STATE
SENATE CAN PROMPT IN HIS
DEBATE WITH DR. BECAUSE THEY
ARE TRYING TO TURN HIM INTO
A HERO FOR THE DISABILITY
MOVEMENT THAT JUST MADE ONE
AUDIENCE MEMBER SAID TO HER
STOMACH.
SHE IS NOW THAT ROSIE OF MP
WHITE MEN WHO HIDE THEIR
CONDITION.
A SLEW OF POSITIVE HEADLINE.
WHEN ALL HE DID WAS BARK OUT
CONFUSING HALF SENTENCES.
DEBATE HIGHLIGHTS ABLE -ISM
IN POLITICS.
HE CAN DO FOR DISABILITY
WHAT OBAMA DID FOR RACE.
BUT LAWRENCE O'DONNELL WENT
A STEP FURTHER.
>> WINSTON CHURCHILL HAVE
THE GOOD FORTUNE TO SERVE AS
THE HIDE ELECTED OFFICIALS
LONG BEFORE TELEVISION
COVERED THERE BELIEVE THAT
IT WOULD BE PAINFUL TO WATCH
, AND PAINFUL TO WATCH
BECAME AN OFTEN REPEATED
PHRASE ON TWITTER DURING THE
SENATE CAMPAIGN DEBATE.
>> HE WAS PAINFUL TO WATCH.
HE HAS A POINT VERY HE HAS
SOMETHING IN COMMON WITH AN
FDR.
AND HAVE MADE A
COHERENT STATEMENT
IN A LONG LONG TIME.
WHICH BRINGS US TO
SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER
WHO HAD THIS TO SAY
TO BIDEN ON A HOT
MIKE REGARDING THE
PERFORMANCE.
>> [INDISCERNIBLE]
>> IF YOU NOTICE AND
YOU LOOK CLOSELY YOU
WILL SEE THAT BIDEN
IS ACTUALLY CROSSING
HIS FINGERS THEY ARE
.
YOU CAN SEE THAT.
HE'S EITHER GRATEFUL
FOR THE NEWS OR JUST
HOPING THAT WAS JUST
A PART
WE HAVE ALL BEEN
THERE.
SPEAKING OF THINGS
SPINNING OUT OF
CONTROL, PRESIDENT
OF BIDEN APPEARED ON
THE MORE THAN ONE
HOUSE PER HOUR IN
HIS 67 CORVETTE.
IT WAS EASY TO PICK
OUT JO'S CAR SOMEONE
WITH THE TURN SIGNAL
ON THE WHOLE TIME.
IMAGINE THAT SMALL.
SWEAT.
HERE IS FOOTAGE THAT
DIDN'T MAKE THE CUT.
>> THE NEED FOR
SPEED.
LET'S GO, MAN.
LET'S GET THE RADIO.
>> HIS RATINGS OUR
IN THE TOILET.
>> COME ON, MAN.
>> READY TO PUSH
FROM THE SIDE.
>> I'M NOT LISTENING
ANYMORE.
STANDS AT 33%.
[APPLAUSE]
>> IT'S LIKE CLOCKWORK, TYRUS
PETER NOW THAT IT'S A PROTECTED
CLASS.
THEY DID THAT WITH THE VICE
PRESIDENT, LIKE ANYBODY WITH
ANYONE TRYING TO BE NATIVE
AMERICAN AND THEY TRY TO CREATE
A PROTECTED CLASS.
NOW WHO IS PART OF THE
DISABILITY CLASS.
HE IS NOT HERE IS THE THING, IT
IS NOT LIKE HE DIDN'T KNOW THAT
HE SUFFERED A STROKE PICKED THE
COVERED IT UP BECAUSE THE SEED
WAS MORE IMPORTANT THAN WHETHER
HE COULD ACTUALLY PERFORM THE
JOB I COME FROM SIMULATED COMBAT
, WHICH IS WRESTLING.
AND WE'VE BEEN KNOWN TO STAGE
AND INTERVIEW LIKE SCHUMER JUST
DID.
I DIDN'T NOTICE IT WAS THAT BAD
BUT WERE GOING TO BE OKAY THE
PROBLEM WAS HE MADE SURE THAT
THE PRESIDENT DID NOT APPEAR ON
CAMERA BECAUSE HE HAD NO IDEA
WHAT HE WAS TALKING ABOUT.
SCHUMER POSITIONED HIM THE RIGH
WAY.
AND HE'S NOT REPRESENTING ANYON
BUT HIMSELF.
HE IS REPRESENTING SOMEONE THAT
IS DISHONEST THAT LINE THAT HE'
GOING TO DO FOR DISABILITIES
WHAT OBAMA DID FOR RACE.
THE COUNTRY HAS EVOLVED AND
CHANGED BLACK MEN CAN RUN FOR
PRESIDENT AND EVERYBODY WOULD B
OKAY WITH THAT PREHEATED CHANGE
THE GAME THE GAME WAS CHANGED B
EVERYONE SO HE COULD.
>> NICELY DONE.
I AM THINKING THEY SHOULD GO ON
STEP FURTHER.
THEN I WILL VOTE FOR HIM.
>> BUT FOLLOWING THEIR LOGIC,
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY BE A
COMPASSIONATE VIEW ON YOUR PART.
>> YOU CAN'T BLAME HIM.
IF THEY KNEW IT WOULD GO LIKE
THAT AND BE WORSE, THEY KNOW IT
IS BAD THAT IS WHY SCHUMER IS
SAYING I DON'T KNOW CALLING THA
A HOT MICROPHONE MOMENT, IT IS
NOT LIKE A PROPER THIRST AND
JAKE'S SITUATION.
IF THERE WERE SOME INTELLECTUAL
HONESTY OF THE PEOPLE WOULD
RESPECT IT MORE.
FOR PEOPLE TO SAY THAT WAS
NORMAL AND NOTHING WAS WRONG
WITH THAT,  YOU DON'T HAVE TO B
A GENIUS.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE GONE OUTSIDE
ONE TIME TO KNOW THAT THAT IS
TRUE.
>> HE IS GOING TO PLAY THE
VICTIM CARD AFTER SPENDING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS SAYING DONO
CAMPAIGN DONATIONS AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN HE IS THE VICTIM.
IF HE FEELS THAT WAY, THAN MSNB
MUST HIRE HIM OR THE NEWSPAPER
MOST HIRE THE NEWS REPORTER.
THE THINK IS
>> I DIDN'T SEE WINSTON
CHURCHILL AFTER THE BLITZ SAYIN
GOOD NIGHT, BRITAIN.
SO HE HAS BEEN AN UNKNOWN
QUANTITY TO HIS CAMPAIGN.
NOW TO PLAY THE VICTIM CARD IS
DEEPLY CYNICAL.
>> THEY ARE MAKING THE CLAIM
THAT THIS IS THE PROCESSING
PROBLEM IN A MONITORY PROBLEM.
HE HAD A STROKE, WHICH MEANS
THAT PART OF HIS BRAIN IS GONE.
HE HEAD IN APHASIA, AND IN
ADDITION TO SPEECH, THERE ARE
COGNITIVE DISORDERS ASSOCIATED
WITH IT.
HE WILL COMPENSATE, BUT HE WILL
NEVER BE THE SAME.
IT'S EXCRUCIATING TO WATCH THEM
GO THROUGH THAT.
AWES SHOWED GREAT RESTRAINT
GREAT RATE IT IS VERY CONCERNING
.
WHAT IS TRUE FOR ME IS HOW FAR
ARE WE GOING GREAT HOW MUCH
BRAIN DAMAGE BEFORE WE SAY
SOMEBODY IS NOT OKAY.
IS A TAFT FLEX DOES A WHOLE
VORTEX NEED TO GO?
HE HAS PARIETAL DAMAGE BRICKEY
THEY ARE SAYING IT'S FAIR.
>> IT IS EXCRUCIATING TO SEE
THIS HAPPENING.
IT IS PAINFUL TO WATCH GREAT,
BUT THE QUESTION AND MY MIND IS
HOW FAR ARE WE GOING WITH THIS?
HOW MUCH DOES YOUR BRAIN HAVE T
DYSFUNCTION BEFORE WE ARE HONES
ABOUT WHAT THE DYSFUNCTION IS
RIGHT YOU WANT HIM TO FLY AN
AIRPLANE OR BEING YOUR SURGEON?
I MEAN WHERE DO WE DRAW THE LIN
ON THESE THINGS IF WE ARE NOT
REALISTIC?
>> IF I WOULD'VE WORKED FOR HIM
I WOULD HAVE STOPPED IT.
>> YOU KNOW IT'S HAPPENING TO
WITH THE MEDIA IS IT'S ALSO A
DISTRACTION OF WHAT HIS POLICIE
HAVE BEEN, WHICH ARE SO DAMAGIN
AND HAVE BEEN DAMAGING TO GET
THE NO CASH FAILED BAIL.
>> AND, WHAT IS REALLY STRIKING
TO HAVE THE LEFT SAY WE ARE FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS IN SOCIAL JUSTICE
FREIGHT WHAT IS MORE OF THE
CIVIL RIGHTS VIOLATIONS IN AN
INNOCENT AMERICAN BEING MURDERE
BECAUSE SOMEONE IS LET OUT OF
JAIL EARLY THAT'S UP MURDER ARE.
>> I LIKE HOW YOU EXPLAIN WHAT
THAT IS TO ME, IF I EVER COME
DOWN WITH SOMETHING, I WANT YOU
TO EXPLAIN IT TO ME.
>> CAN WE START RIGHT NOW?
COULD KEEP WHATEVER YOU NEED, I
WILL SIGN.
>> IF THERE'S EVER ANYTHING
WRONG.
>> AS A MATTER OF FACT, I WILL
GIVE YOU THE POWER OF MY
ATTORNEY.
>> OKAY.
GREATS.
I'M GLAD YOU GUYS HAD A LOT OF
FUN